hi everyone uh i'm drewmar i'm product
science
from product graph team on amazon so
today i'm going to talk about our paper
about the building knowledge graph of
amazon products
so as you know the amazon we sell a lot
of products to customers
and we have very big inventory it's a
compelling idea that we can build a
knowledge graph for all the amazon
products
so we can better serve the search
applications and
better recommendations and better answer
customer questions
so the knowledge graph about product
will look like this
uh we have this product here we have
this uh associated attributes we have
the attribute values
um it looks pretty simple but if you
think about how many products we have
and how many attribute values we have
and for all these links
uh are they correct not correct are they
complete or not complete
so it's a much more challenging problem
than you thought
so what exactly are these challenges the
first one
is a structure especially um so ideally
when you build a nodule graph you want
to have those attributes
uh values or field from some structure
of data
but in reality we don't for many
products we just have descriptions
and you have to figure out what type the
size color is so that's the first
challenge second challenge is that a
domain complexity
uh which means you have millions of
product types of various relationships
look at here for this product you have
clothes furniture grocery and for
grocery you have a snack string
seafood and for these types if you think
about the relations
there are subtypes one product of type
is actually a subtype of another one
and some product types might be sent
into each other and some types actually
might be overlapping with each other
this all makes a problem more complex
and we have the product type variety
challenge here
so what it means is uh there are
different values for capital for
different product types
take one example so here we're looking
at the attribute called size
and the size means different things for
uh for different product type for tv
it means 58 inch for tee box the size
and 48 count
for coffee bags 20 oz that means you
cannot build a single model that handles
all the product types together because
the vocabulary changes the product type
changes is very challenging
so we have a long way to go with a lot
of challenges our solution is the
autonomous
is a self-driving technology collection
so here's a high level intuition
what you start with are these taxonomy
pre-existing taxonomy
uh we have user logs basically what the
customer clicks what customer buys and
what's our credit we're searching for
we have catalog so the catalog data is
not
perfect so we have the wrong values we
also have some the for example product
2.
it doesn't have flavor any color so
through
out to know we're going to build an
improved knowledge graph
so if we compare this taxonomy here with
the print
with the existing taxonomy you see we
have a new uh
concept identified the prep cells the
pretzels actually
is a type of snacks this is something we
identified we fixed the value for
product one
and for product two we added the values
and also identify the chocolate and
chocolate synonyms
and then with this a better product
graph we can actually
answer questions better and better
solving the exact match
searches and also explain more
recommendations so the self-driving uh
has these four features automatic uh of
the curse not surprising we're using
machine learning models to leverage data
itself
uh it's all annotation free we use a lot
of distance supervision
semi supervision to remove the burden of
annotates and when size fits all we love
transfer learning so we can build one
big model then can face different
multi-dom multiple domains
and also we have the sites of guidance
which means uh
we look at the customer behavior data
and try to figure out
new types new concepts and new
attributes by itself
so here is the architecture of the
self-driving collection
so besides the input data and output we
have the two suits the ontology suits
have taxonomy enrichment
and relation discovery uh textile
enrichment means to
find new concepts uh new attributes and
the relation discoveries can be
associated with existing
taxonomy we also have the data suit we
have a data imputation
which extract values from the titles
queries
we have data cleaning parts we clean the
data and we have the center discovery
which find the synonym attributes values
so i'm going to skip the technique
details um you should look for
look at the details in paper so
these experiments we tested on four
major product domains
there are over 30 million products over
one billion triples you can see the
precision recoil
and f measure or had improved
significantly we also
reduced the defect rates so autonomous
is a
collaboration between amazon scientists
and engineers
also researchers from a couple of
universities you're welcome to check our
paper and
send us email if you have questions